[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAE WANG: OK, hello.
We're starting.
Thank you for coming to the
Bringing the Cloud to You
session.
This morning, you have
all been to the keynote
and heard about exciting
Anthos announcement.
So here, we have a panel of
the product and engineering
leaders responsible for
creating Anthos to answer
any questions you might have.
First, we're going to
introduce ourselves.
So here's the rule
for our panelists.
Everybody's going to tell the
audience your name, your role,
and your favorite song
that describes CSP,
and bonus points if
you're able to sing.
So I can start.
[LAUGHS] My name is Rae Wang.
I lead a product team for
identity config and policy
management for CSP.
My song is John
Lennon's "Imagine."
Imagine all the workloads
living life in peace.
OK, let's start from that side.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: Right, so
my name is Alberto Maestro.
I'm a product manager at Google.
And my song is "Don't Stop
Believing" by Journey,
given that we are all
together in this journey.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Thank you.
You didn't sing.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: We're going
to lose a lot of customers.
JESS LEROY: That's a
really hard song to sing.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Chen Goldberg.
I'm the engineering director
leading many of the Anthos
engineering teams.
And my song is "Think" by Aretha
Franklin, like the freedom.
And the reason why
I know I can sing it
because I used the Google Home.
I sang it to it, and then
it told me what the song is.
JESS LEROY: Hey.
My name's Jess Leroy,
director of product management
on the security side.
Let's see.
My song for this was
"Signed, Sealed, Delivered."
I went super ultra cheesy
because as the security
guy, signed was certificates,
sealed with GKE security,
and delivered through Anthos.
So-- oh, right.
Here I am, baby, signed,
sealed, delivered.
I'm yours.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Woohoo.
[APPLAUSE]
APARNA SINHA: Great, wow.
My name is Aparna Sinha.
I lead the product team
for Kubernetes, GKE,
now what's called what's part
of Anthos, GKE On Prem, and GKE
Migrate or Anthos Migrate.
My song for Anthos, I haven't
done a lot of thinking,
so just kind of mainstream,
"End Game" by Taylor Swift.
I hope that Anthos is, for
our customers, the end game.
RAE WANG: Going to sing?
APARNA SINHA: Oh, gosh.
We want to be your
end game, end game.
We want to be your A team.
RAE WANG: Cool.
You want to keep it for now.
APARNA SINHA: Oh, OK.
JESS LEROY: Wait, you
don't have to sing?
RAE WANG: Imagine all the
workloads living life in peace.
JESS LEROY: Nice.
APARNA SINHA: Nice.
RAE WANG: OK, we also--
just to test whether
you read slides or not,
we're putting a little test.
Who do you think is
missing from stage?
Jennifer's missing.
You've seen her at
a keynote today.
She needs to go to a
last minute press event,
so we're going to pretend to
be her and answer questions
for her here.
OK, so after the
announcement this morning,
I walked around Moscone Center.
Can you believe how many
people that there are today?
And asked current
people, what are
some of the burning questions
on their mind about Anthos?
And I compiled some of them.
So we're going to start from a
few questions from that list.
And then we'll open up to
live audience questions.
So the very first question,
everybody wants to know,
why did we change the name
from Cloud Service Platform
to Anthos?
Aparna, what do you think?
APARNA SINHA: OK,
so Anthos is Greek.
Cloud Services
Platform is not Greek.
A lot of the
components are named
in Greek, like Kubernetes,
and Istio, and Knative.
So Anthos is a
more apropos name.
Also, Anthos means
bringing something to life.
And we believe that
Anthos is a game changer.
It's something that is bringing
a change in the industry that
hasn't been there
before because it's
removing the risk of being
multi-cloud and giving users
choice.
So that's why the name
Anthos for the platform,
bringing life to multi-cloud.
RAE WANG: Great.
Thank you.
OK, then now we know the name.
Then we want to talk about
what is division of Anthos,
and why are enterprises
excited about it?
Alberto, do you want
to talk to that?
ALBERTO MAESTRO: It's
been a phenomenal journey
over the last many years
that we've been implementing
the vision of Cloud,
and our customers
have been pretty amazing
with lots of technologies.
We have gone through
many iterations
of application modernizations,
platform as a service.
And when we launched
Kubernetes, we struck a chord.
We actually-- the industry
sent us signals that this
is a model that worked for us.
With Anthos, what
we are bringing
is that operational model.
We are bringing it everywhere.
We are actually
complementing with a lot
of other technologies,
such as they have an end
to end solutions
that they can start
using to modernize and transform
their enterprises today.
That flexibility is based on
our open source investments.
And that makes that
platform open--
open around everywhere
and being able to enable
an open ecosystem of partners
that will help us deliver all
of the technology that is
needed for those enterprises
to be successful.
RAE WANG: Cool.
Thank you.
Let's go to Chen next.
Have we heard from
any other customers
on how Anthos improved their
development and release
velocity?
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes.
Actually, we had today
in the spotlight session,
we had two customers that
have been using Anthos, HSBC
and [INAUDIBLE].
And it's important to say that
ever since we have announced
CSP eight months ago, we were
mostly focusing about working
with our customers.
And Anthos is a platform, a
product that puts users first.
Anthos gives customers choice.
So they want to get the
agility and velocity
that the cloud
promised them to have,
but it also introduced
new risk for them.
For example, how do you manage
those multiple environments?
How do you verify and approve
new services, meet the bar,
and your developers can use it?
How do you make sure that your
talent is not spread too thin.
So we heard today, for
example, from HSBC,
how they're excited
that Anthos gives them
that velocity, both on-prem,
where they have worked with.
They are not intending to
move, and they have regulation
they want to meet, and on GCP.
That was one example.
Hisham from [INAUDIBLE]
said that Anthos helps him,
of course, with agility.
But he was focusing
about how it helps
him to build the best team.
Because when we talk about
digital transformation,
it starts with the people.
And by bringing an Anthos
into his organization,
he can attract the
best talent by letting
developers use the newest
technologies out there.
He gives developers the
choice to use whatever
services they want,
and they can really
use and focus on bringing
value, because they
are using managed product.
So those are just two
examples of how customers
were excited about Anthos.
RAE WANG: OK, great.
Thank you.
Now, they're excited about it.
We know some of them
also have started
testing in their environments
some even in their production
environment.
Aparna, can you
tell us what they've
been doing with Anthos
in the environment?
APARNA SINHA: Sure, so
in the case of HSBC,
they're looking to have
a centralized development
environment, where all of their
different lines of business--
so it's a big bank.
It's a global bank.
They've got the retail banking,
the commercial banking,
the wealth management group.
And they want to have a
centralized development
platform that's on-prem, that
all these groups can basically
develop on.
And like many banks-- actually,
Scotiabank is very similar--
they want a separation
of concerns between what
the developers access--
and that layer should be
something that's really
super-simple, fast for them
to get started and roll
applications out--
versus what the
operators access.
And what the
operators access has
to be something where
there's centralized control,
and they can implement
enterprise policies
to make sure that
all their compliance
and regulatory
requirements are met.
When you think about the banks,
they have, in the case of HSBC,
they said, 40,000 developers.
So there's a variety of
different skill levels.
Some of them are with the bank.
Some of them are contractors.
And so they want really
a simplified interface
for development, but a very
tightly-controlled environment
for compliance and
regulatory and security.
And the reason they want GKE
On-Prem is so that they have
a consistent environment
that when they move
to the cloud, everything
they've built is cloud-ready,
and they can just
move it to the cloud.
So that's one example.
We had another
example of Kohl's.
Kohl's is a retailer.
They have many, many stores,
I think, 1,800-or-some stores.
And they want an environment
in each of those stores that's
kind of a compact
environment, but has
the compute that's required.
And they can do
continuous integration,
continuous delivery from
a centralized cloud-based
development platform,
and then deliver
to those retail locations.
So those are two examples
of Anthos in action.
RAE WANG: Great.
Thank you.
Have something to add?
CHEN GOLDBERG: And I can
add about Cardinal Health
that they've been trying
out Anthos Migrate
and moving from
VMs to containers.
So they've been
migrating to cloud,
and they were excited
to actually get
the observability capabilities
into their environment.
So by moving from
VMs to Kubernetes,
they already get a
better service operator
experience automatically.
RAE WANG: Great.
Thank you.
So when we think about
these industries,
whether it's in our banking,
our retail, our health care,
we know that security is top of
mind for all of these, I think.
So, Jess, why don't
you tell us about how
we think about security
in the hybrid world.
JESS ELROY: Yeah.
OK, so over the course of
2019, as we look at this year,
we've sort of got four
main pillars of work
that we're doing.
And they tie into the way that
Anthos looks at the world.
So we think of security
of the cloud, which
are all of the different
security controls that we built
in, all the compliance and
regulatory compliance that we
do, all of the
default encryption,
and strong authentication
on connections.
You don't have to do anything
in order to get those things.
Then security in the
cloud, where we provide you
with all of the
configurations and options
that you create your
own security settings
and portfolios from.
Those are your firewall
settings, your VPC Service
Controls for logical
boundaries, IM and org policies.
And then security services--
so this year, you'll
see new things from
us on the services
side, where we are
building services
on top of those things.
And then our fourth goal
is around securing Anthos.
So all of the work
that we're doing
needs to be portable to Anthos.
So we are taking the
best of GKE security,
Istio security, secure
pipelines through GKE,
secure connections, and Envoy
and certificates through Istio,
and leveraging all of
that through Anthos.
So we're securing
the platform itself,
On-Prem, and as you
migrate, you get
all the benefits of the other
pieces in the cloud as well.
So it's a really nice fit.
Those security services
that I was talking about,
we'll announce a bunch
of those tomorrow.
And you'll see us start
to push those down
towards Anthos as well over
the course of this year.
RAE WANG: That's a top
benefit for Anthos,
even without moving
your workloads off-prem,
you can already start to benefit
from a lot of these security
value from [INAUDIBLE].
Cool.
Another big
announcement from Anthos
this morning was
our Marketplace.
So, Alberto, why
don't you tell us
what it means to customers,
especially to enterprises.
ALBERTO MAESTRO:
I'm super-excited
about the Marketplace.
The reason being is because now
that we have a platform where
customers can start
investing and building
their applications, they have
the need to run the existing--
the way they manage
the existing solutions
it was as laborious as they were
building their own platform.
So we have the opportunity
to actually help
our partners come
into the platform
and meet their customers
on the platform,
and simplify the
operational process,
the procurement process, such as
all our customers can find all
their applications, all
the services that they need
at the click of
a button and have
the whole lifecycle in ensuring
that those services are deliver
in a consistent way.
One of the things that customers
tell us is that, yeah, great,
we love your platform.
But when something goes wrong,
who do I have to talk to?
So a lot of
investment is going on
to make sure that there
is a consistent way
to deliver and run those
services in Anthos such
that our customers have
a consistent experience,
and they can actually
spend more time just
building their applications
versus trying to figure out
what throat to choke.
RAE WANG: Great.
Thank you.
OK, so I will wait a
little bit to come back
to the Moscone questions.
Let's come back to this room.
We can open for live questions.
Lucy has the mic.
AUDIENCE: So the last
year at GCP Next, the CSD
was announced, right?
And as part of that,
the GKE On-Prem
was part of that offering,
and then Managed Istio
was one of them, right?
And now, we have Anthos.
So has that been a change
in strategy from last year,
or is it just an extension of--
APARNA SINHA: Yeah, so
no change in strategy.
So the announcement
from last year,
we've taken it
forward next step.
GKE On-Prem, what we announced
as part of Anthos, is now GA.
And we saw tremendous demand
when we announced it last year.
I think we mentioned
in our spotlight,
we had over 1,000
customers sign up.
And so we took that
customer feedback.
We actually worked directly
with those customers
to bring the product
through alpha,
beta, and now,
announced GA here today.
What we've done,
though, in addition
is we've added
several components
into the overall
platform that is Anthos.
Last year, we also announced the
config management capability,
which is from a single
source of truth.
Across all your
different environments
and all your different clusters,
you can deploy policies--
RBAC policies, quota policies,
a number of different policies.
That also moved to GA.
And last year was when we
announced the introduction
of the Marketplace.
And as Alberto stated,
that has also moved to GA.
So those three components
very tightly moved to GA
as part of Anthos.
And of course, the Managed
Istio piece-- the Managed Istio
piece, I think, we previously
announced that as beta in GKE.
And we're moving forward.
And over the course
of our roadmap
this year, we'll be bringing
that to the rest of Anthos.
AUDIENCE: I have
one more question
about the Anthos Migrate.
So that's a new thing.
That was not something which
was there last year, right?
And I think you
mentioned that there
are some customers who are
already leveraging it or using
that, right?
I'm just trying to understand--
because we come
from a legacy world.
And we are migrating
applications to the cloud.
And how easy, in that case,
wood Anthos Migrate be?
Because you're dealing
with monolith application
with different databases,
and then we use
managed services or managed
databases in the cloud.
So in that case, would
Anthos Migrate be applicable,
or is it something
where you already
built cloud-native applications,
and only then you can use it?
APARNA SINHA: No,
actually, Anthos Migrate,
it's one of two new capabilities
as part of Anthos this year.
So we talked about
what moved to GA--
just the three or four
capabilities we talked about
last year--
and the two new capabilities
that we introduced this year.
One is Anthos Migrate, which
takes your existing monoliths,
including your
databases, some things,
like Sybase, your WebSphere.
We showed a CRM
application, SugarCRM.
So very much existing,
what you might call,
packaged applications,
where you might not even
have the source code, that's
what Anthos Migrate targets.
And it moves that as a
system container into GKE.
And we announced that
that capability--
It's brand new.
It's something that,
I think, is kind
of a first in the
industry, particularly
given the speed and the
simplicity of the migration.
So we showed a demo
in our spotlight,
where it was less
than five minutes.
Of course, we were
biting our nails.
But we did the migration
right there on the stage.
Kicked it off, and
then completed it
right there on the
stage in five minutes
into a system
container, bringing you
the benefits of the bin packing,
the benefits of the isolation
from the OS
patching, and freedom
from the VM and, of
course, bringing you
into a tool chain, where you
have Managed Istio enabled
in that GKE environment.
So you can view
that CRM system now.
Still a monolith as a service
in Stackdriver and so forth
and set security policy.
So it brings it into
the Anthos framework.
That's why it's
called Anthos Migrate.
And yet, we do that
with zero code changes,
so not breaking the monolith.
But I do want to say
that's the first step.
That's just the first step.
You may want to break
the monolith, ultimately.
Certainly, the customers that
I have that are on Sybase,
they don't intend to
be Sybase forever.
They are thinking
of breaking it.
But this is a good first step.
How easy is it to do?
It's not that difficult. It's
actually surprisingly easy.
It's based on and built on using
the same technology that you'd
used for VM-to-VM
migration, which
we acquired through a
company called Velostrata.
And so it's actually
fairly enterprise-ready
But there is setup involved.
You have to set up the agent
in your vSphere environment.
But it's actually
quite rich, and we've
got a handful of customers
that are doing this already.
We mentioned Cardinal Health.
We actually mentioned a
couple others on stage.
And it's pretty versatile.
This is just the
beginning of our roadmap.
So you can migrate
from VMware on-prem.
You can also migrate
from VMs and AWS.
And in future, the destination--
right now, it's just GKE in
the cloud, but in the future,
it will also be GKE On-Prem.
And we'll continue adding
applications to it.
CHEN GOLDBERG: I would
just like to add just
to complete the picture.
You asked, well, this
is a change of strategy.
And we talked about what was
added this year around Anthos.
So we mentioned
the Anthos Migrate.
We also talked about
the multi-cloud
this time for the first time.
So already, last year, we
talked about connecting
all your Kubernetes
environments,
your GKE environments from
a single control plane,
from a single pane of glass.
And this year, we're talking
about connecting any Kubernetes
cluster into that
environment and actually
applying similar policies, and
tools, and experience on there.
And the third thing-- actually,
I will add two more things--
we also did the Cloud Run.
So we demoed that today.
So everything we do here is
about engineering velocity.
They don't really
care about Kubernetes.
So we are helping customers
with Cloud Run move
from a container image
to a running application,
internet-facing running
application in seconds.
It's that easy, and
we also showed that.
So that'll be the other
thing that we have added.
And the last thing,
which I'm very happy,
which also part of the
Marketplace and so on
is really the ecosystem that
is built on top of Anthos.
So TK today in his keynote
spent much of his time
talking about the partnerships,
if it's hardware, software.
You saw their system
integrated-- it was ISV--
really having that support and
community in delivering Anthos.
So that would be the complete
new things in Anthos.
But this is really the
next step as we see it
in the journey in modernization.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
Kuna from [INAUDIBLE].
So you guys touched on
a couple of things--
breaking up the
monolith, multi-cloud.
I had a question.
I was talking to Lucy
about this earlier.
The Anthos things
looks very cool,
but it seems to assume that
your application runs completely
and entirely inside Kubernetes.
What if you tried to make
use of cloud-native services,
like Pub/Sub, or even
Amazon queuing services?
Do you guys have
any plans for Anthos
to support things
outside of Kubernetes?
I'm not sure if
that makes sense.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: Absolutely.
So one of the things that have
come in throughout the year,
we have a very rich
roadmap of capabilities
that are becoming part of
Anthos throughout the year.
And we have talked
in many sessions
around our Istio technology
and service mesh.
And one of our
goals is making sure
that whatever the
workload is running,
we give you the capabilities
to manage how any workload--
wherever they are and
how it is implemented--
how we can actually help you
manage the data plane between
the VM and the container, a VM
and a VM, a VM and a service,
a container-- all
the permutations--
effectively gives you
the same policy system
that we are implementing
today to manage effectively
containerized workloads.
We will give you the same
capabilities to manage the data
plane and, therefore, connecting
and modernizing the way all
applications that
you are running--
whatever they are running,
however they have been
implemented--
we'll give you
those capabilities.
So that's one of the
investments that we are doing.
And we will shape it
throughout the year.
Is there anything else
that you guys want to add?
Great.
So there's many levels of how we
are enabling managed services.
One of the principles that
we are applying to Anthos
is that when we think
about the services
that we bring into
Anthos is that we're
going to treat first party and
third-party services the same.
We want to give you exactly
the same consistency
that we are bringing
into the platform
with first-party services.
We want to bring
the same consistency
to third-party services.
Our goal is to make sure
that whatever services
that we bring into Anthos
work everywhere where
you want Anthos to run.
That is one of our goals,
and the journey just started.
One of the things that we are
announcing throughout Next
is the Kubernetes Marketplace
and all the partners
that we have in the Kubernetes
Marketplace, but also,
some things that are
truly [INAUDIBLE]..
For example, Palo Alto
Networks have actually
shaped as part of the
Kubernetes Marketplace
the capability of integrating
the threat detection appliance
with one click of a button.
So you have a
Kubernetes environment.
You deploy this adapter.
And that connects your
threat detection appliance
to your Anthos
service mesh, such
as you get all of
that capability
without having to
change any code.
And we'll see that there
is a lot of services
that we are going to
bring into Anthos that
are going to give you all the
capabilities that you need
to be able, not just to
modernize your application,
but also integrate with
existing applications.
AUDIENCE: Maybe a related
question to that as well.
So I work in the BI space.
And in the BI space,
you have everything
from data storage, ETL, data
warehouse, semantic models,
and then you have
your visualizations.
I don't see how Anthos
can help migrate that.
If it can, it'll be great.
Because one of the things
is that Google is not
available in China.
So if we are able to
migrate a workload that
is in Google to another cloud
that is available in China
as is, that would be great.
But I am still having a
hard time understanding
how Anthos will help in
this particular situation.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah,
so Anthos is not
a platform that needs
to be in Google Cloud.
So, for example, when
we talked to HSBC,
they are running in regions
where Google Cloud is not
available.
AUDIENCE: No, I understand that.
But I want to understand how
data warehousing application--
because the word, application,
to me, the way it's being used
is user front-end applications.
I can see that.
But when you have an
ecosystem of components
that forms a data
warehouse application,
how is that planed
to be migrated?
APARNA SINHA: So
it's not necessarily
meant to be migrated.
It sort of depends on
whether the customer
wishes to migrate
their data warehouse,
including all parts
of the data warehouse.
So I'm not sure
if I'm necessarily
answering your question.
But the example that I would
give of a regulated company,
which is HSBC, is that they're
running in environments where
there's no cloud available.
For example, they're
in Saudi Arabia.
China is similar.
And they have data that
they need to keep on-prem
for regulatory reasons.
They're not moving to the cloud.
And so the benefit of
actually the on-prem component
of Anthos, which is GKE
On-Prem, the reason that they're
using it is because it gives
them a consistent environment.
It's not in the cloud, but it's
an environment that's very--
that's why we say,
bringing the cloud to you.
Because we're bringing the cloud
to your on-prem environment.
And you run it the same way that
you would run it in the cloud.
Your data warehouse may or may
not be running in Kubernetes.
Your data warehouse may
be running outside, right?
It's running outside.
But it can still
use the capabilities
of service management
and of policy management
as long as you can expose your
application, your various parts
of your data warehouse
application and services.
And so the niche case--
Mani talked about this
in the spotlight--
he said that he wants
everything in his environment
to be a service.
He wants the data that is
on-prem to be front-ended
by a service that can be
accessed through a set of APIs.
And that is something
that he wants
to manage as a
standard in his on-prem
as well as in the cloud.
So that's the way, at least
in the Anthos philosophy,
that we would manage
an on-prem use.
ALBERTO MAESTRO:
I think understood
a nuance of the question,
which I hinted it before.
Before Anthos, it used to be
called Cloud Services Platform.
And the actual name
means that we wanted
it's a platform for services.
And we are working
with our customers,
and we are listening to you.
And we are going
to bring whatever
services that we need to
bring to Anthos, whether it's
first party or third
party, to make sure
that it addresses your needs.
Today, we are setting
up just the foundation
of that platform.
But we are working very
closely with our customers
to understand, not just that
you need the capabilities to run
your applications
on the platform,
but what services do you need
to be available on the platform?
I'm excited, because our
third-party partners can
actually get there very fast.
We're working with them to bring
a lot of those services there.
Of course, we are working
with our customers,
and figuring out, is their
first-party services that you
want to see in that platform?
And having that conversation to
make sure that at some point,
you have all that you need.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And
probably something
that you've also
been thinking about,
you don't want to containerize
or migrate everything
like that.
You can actually move
to a managed product.
So we have our own data
warehouse services.
We've just acquired Alooma,
which also helps migrating.
AUDIENCE: It's not
available in China.
CHEN GOLDBERG: OK.
So I'm just saying that
that's the things that--
on top of that, we are also
moving services to the cloud.
RAE WANG: So I'm
actually working
with a number of customers
who need to run potentially
on other public
clouds in environments
where Google doesn't
have a data center.
And when we talked
to them about,
how do you make your
workloads portable
between multiple clouds?
The only obvious
solution is going with--
whether it's in compute, or
storage, in other places--
going with open
source standards.
So they're using open source
standards for their workloads,
and then using a
managed control plane.
And as Alberto said,
we're starting,
I think, from a compute
workloads and API
management, policy management.
Kind of definitely
understand that it
takes a much larger stack
for inter application.
And some of these
early customers
are starting to use the
well-known open source
storage and database products.
And we're looking
at more and more
to make that managed
experience easier
for you to run multiple calls.
AUDIENCE: OK, that might
have answered my question.
But my company does
manufacturing in China,
and we'd like to have a
point of presence there.
But so far, because we run
everything on Google Cloud,
we haven't been able to.
And I guess, are
there any partners
that have managed to use
Anthos to sort of create
that point of presence
in, say, on the factory
floor for this kind of purpose?
And how easy is it?
RAE WANG: So
specifically for China,
why don't we connect offline?
We're not yet ready
to announce, but we
are looking at some of these
special region use cases.
Let's talk offline.
AUDIENCE: Hi-- quick question.
So it's actually more a
suggestion than anything,
but maybe you want to hear.
So you really, really helpful
for moving VM to Kubernetes.
That's great.
But I already bought OpenShift.
I'm running this
environment there.
Can you help me migrate it?
Same thing that I
will ask on any other
Kubernetes that I'm
open source using.
I think that would be a
huge, huge buy for you guys,
specifically,
considering the market.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: Makes sense.
Kubernetes is the foundation
for a lot of these platforms,
and we're working with our
partners to figure out,
what is the things
that our customers need
to be successful?
So of course, that's our focus--
making customers successful.
CHEN GOLDBERG: Yes,
and I would say,
the key thing here is
talking about the experience,
because we do have the
possibility of workload
between those environments.
So that's actually
already exists.
And usually, users really
appreciate that experience
and the ecosystem.
So that depends really on
what the customer needs.
AUDIENCE: But in
OpenShift, there
is more than just a regular,
vanilla Kubernetes, right?
I mean, it would be
very helpful if you
will be able to do all these
configurations I already
configure in this environment
and help me to move it.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah,
so definitely.
Actually, I would say that
the challenge of migrating
from a VM to GKE is
a bigger challenge
than moving from OpenShift
to Anthos or GKE.
It is actually much
easier, because you already
have a set of YAML,
and there's only
a couple of objects in
OpenShift that are different.
There's a different CLI.
You can, essentially,
do the migration
without any sort of tooling.
It's not that complicated.
Chen mentioned our
multi-cluster capability--
our multi-cluster, multi-cloud
registration capability.
So currently, that is for a
number of different conformant
distributions of Kubernetes.
I think we will work to
bring OpenShift into that.
So you can have an OpenShift
cluster, and a GKE On-Prem
cluster, and a
kops cluster in AWS
or wherever it is that you want
and view all of your workloads
and all of your resources
from a single place
and also to deploy workloads
across those clusters.
So in that sense,
we'd like users
to be able to manage
their Kubernetes
environments the same.
If there's a migration
from OpenShift to GKE,
I don't think that
that's complicated.
But perhaps, your question was
about the developer experience,
because there is a
pass, essentially,
right, that's built
on top of Kubernetes,
in the case of OpenShift.
And Anthos is a lot more
modular in that sense.
So there is the
cluster management,
multi-cluster management layer.
There is also an
additional, what we call,
module, which has the
developer experience.
And that developer experience
is essentially Cloud Run.
I don't know if you've tried it.
It's extremely simple, and it
is based underneath on Knative.
It's a hosted
offering of Knative,
and so it has automated
serving capabilities
that, for a developer, you can
essentially go from your source
code or a container
in a registry
and within less than a minute.
So in seconds, you have an
externally exposed endpoint
that is your application.
And it is automatically scaled.
You don't have to know
what a deployment is.
what a service is.
You don't have to set
up any kind of ingress.
You don't even have to
know about the cluster.
That can all be done for
you by some central admin.
So with Cloud Run--
and that's really, I think,
it's a pass essentially.
With Cloud Run, you
get all of that set up.
And as you get more traffic,
the system automatically
scales the pods, scales the
cluster both up and down.
So all of that is what is the
Anthos developer experience.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is probably a little bit
confusing, and that's where
the ethos of the question is.
Let me try to give a story, and
I'll try to bring it together
in the question.
So we, in middle
management, have
to work with the engineering
teams, the developers.
And you answered a
part of my question
over there with Cloud Run--
how it can be write
once and used many times
or write one and run many times.
But then we have to make a
case to senior management
or the finance team when they're
actually signing the bill,
what's the value prop
with all these services?
What's the value
prop with Anthos?
Why should we go
from just a Compute
Engine, where we are not running
on workloads in the cloud?
We did convince them
about Kubernetes.
about a managed offering.
But then what's the value
prop with all these services?
And what is it going to
cost us versus having
our own developers spend some
time building and managing
things on top of compute?
Because I'll borrow from
what my friend said,
we are still a legacy company.
Cloud development has a
lot of philosophy, right?
Even before we can keep up
with it, new abilities come up,
new facilities come up.
There are new marketplaces
which come up.
So my point is,
while a part of it
was already answered with
Cloud Run, what's the value
prop in these services
that we can imbibe them
in our work flow, or we can
think about moving to them
in the future?
So does that help?
I'm sorry if it's confusing,
but that's, as I said,
it's the ethos of where we
are in middle management.
APARNA SINHA: I
think several of us
probably want to
answer this question.
Let me just give a brief answer.
From the CIO's perspective,
the top line about Anthos
is that it minimizes or
removes the risk of lock-in,
and it maximizes your choice.
It gives you the choice
to deploy anywhere.
And that's great.
When you bring it
down, the piece
that you don't have--
so you mentioned you've
got the environment
running already.
The piece that you don't have--
there's several pieces--
but one of the pieces
is, you don't have a
multi-cluster management
capability.
That's something that's
unique in Anthos,
and it spans multiple clouds
for workload management.
You don't really have the
centralized policy and security
control.
And that's extremely
important for enterprises.
And then, of course, that
separation of concerns
between developers-- giving
them an easy workflow,
where they don't have
to know the details,
and then giving
the operators all
of the power to control things
at scale in a standard way.
So I think that's what
I would say to the CIO.
Of course, it
comes down to, what
is the TCO of doing it this way
versus doing it sort of ad-hoc,
one-by-one in every
environment, managing
security policy separately, and
having that fragmented state?
That has people cost.
It has platform cost.
It adds risk.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a use
case that you can share,
where somebody was thinking
of moving or have moved?
They're already in transition,
or they're ready to move.
I had to make a TCO case, so OK,
this is where our [INAUDIBLE]
or we can demonstrate
in the future that
is going to be good.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah, so I mean,
we have several such customers.
And they're not
necessarily using
all parts of the platform.
But one that is-- and I don't
know that I can name them,
but it's a retailer, and
they're using GKE in the cloud.
And like I said, they
have almost 1,000 stores.
And they want to be able
to run the same platform.
And they've tried
many different things.
They've tried a lot of
the existing technologies.
But the multi-cluster management
capability, the ability
to distribute workloads
from a single source,
and to be able to manage policy
from a single source, that's
very attractive.
And that's what
they're-- they're like,
I like GKE in the cloud.
It's fully managed.
I want that capability
in my stores.
And if you give me
workload management
on top that's awesome
RAE WANG: And we
are actually working
on a set of white papers
on TCO with example,
so to quantify these values,
it's easier to tell your CIO.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And specifically
talking about, I think,
I know which customer.
So they had to do it themselves.
So they wasted their
talent on a problem
that we can solve for them.
So that's actually clear.
They say, OK, we're going to
get that to be more secured,
and we can innovate more.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: The TCO, as
a preview of what is in there,
you think about it.
You have to run, deploy, and
manage your own Kubernetes
cluster is sort
of starting, then
you have to start out in
Envoy proxies or Orchestration
making sure that all
the upgrades go smooth.
If you start adding all
of the employee costs,
time offline that you need.
Most customers take
their cluster offline
to upgrade them.
So all of that starts adding up.
And you will see that the
value proposition that we bring
with Anthos is very compelling.
That's in the short term,
just immediately, you
can calculate it.
There is an intangible
benefit that we're
trying to drive
with Anthos, which
is also the standardization.
If you think about it, everybody
is running the Kubernetes
in a different way,
which means that it makes
it impossible for
a service provider
to deliver services onto
platform, because they
don't know how to run it.
They don't know which components
you're using, which versions,
or how they've been configured.
So an intangible
value of Anthos,
it is a platform that is common.
That means that it's going
to unlock the opportunity
to have service providers
deliver the services they need,
as we were discussing
before, whether it
be first party or third party.
So there is the short term
total cost of ownership,
but also,
strategically, you want
to invest on a
platform that is going
to have an ecosystem around it.
JESS ELROY: One more small
thing, and we'll move on here.
Part of that process that
you're talking about,
one of those components
that I see a lot
are security and compliance.
And I'm thinking of a meeting
that a partner and I were
in about a week ago, where
a large financial services
firm looking at that
type of TCO, there
is the above-the-line TCO, where
you're going to save money.
You're going to make
money, et cetera.
But there is the
below-the-line, where
you're going to save time and
all of that energy and effort.
For every application
that you want to migrate,
you've got to go
through, and you
have to justify the migration,
plan out the migration.
You've got to assess
all of the security,
and then you have to assess
the compliance underneath that,
too.
Make sure that you're not
going to completely blow up
your compliance state
when you migrate.
So if we can standardize
all of that on Anthos,
then we can really streamline
a big chunk of that process
for the customer.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
regarding Anthos migration,
any plans for
bare-metal migration
as part of moving the
data center to the cloud?
APARNA SINHA: You mean,
migration to bare metal
or migration from bare metal?
AUDIENCE: From.
APARNA SINHA: Right
now, we're very
focused on migrating
existing applications
from virtual machines
to GKE, obviously,
to GCE, and to GKE On-Prem.
And so that's kind of
the roadmap for now.
AUDIENCE: Because the
way I'm seeing it,
we have a lot of
legacy customers, who
are using all the legacy
data centers, which
has application developed
on real bare-metal servers.
Each server has its own
application and stuff
like that, a lot
of customers who
are not using virtual
machines and stuff like that.
And I believe that it
would be helpful for them
if you would be
able to provide them
with an agent that would be able
to migrate them into Anthos.
That would be, as
far as I see it,
a valid use case to move
to Kubernetes and stuff
like that easily.
So that's it.
Thank you.
APARNA SINHA: That's
good feedback.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think I want to take
this a little bit different.
Part of this vision for
Anthos, and the service mesh,
and bringing in the Marketplace,
really, it seems like,
relies on identity
and access management.
I really want to hear
more about what Google
is doing to plug in our existing
identities in access management
environments and systems
into the service mesh.
I don't want to have to reinvent
it for Anthos, because we
already have it.
We are also G Suite
school, so we also
have it in Google already.
RAE WANG: So there's identity
and access management,
kind of talk about
both of them, right?
In terms of identity, some
of the most important changes
coming from service
mesh is, in the past,
we all used service accounts.
You copy key, put it in GitHub,
and all hell breaks loose.
And then, really,
service identity
is as we see the future of
the identity for services.
So we are more and more
looking at best practices
based on service identities
and more and more are
going to try to hide service
account as an implementation
detail.
Really think about it as a
strong identity of services
and try to make you do
as little of the copying
keys as possible.
Eventually, you should
forget about keys.
A strong way to
authenticate your services,
and that's a much safer way
to express your policies.
And then in terms
of user identity,
Anthos allows us to think
about, not only your impasse
is showing employee's identity.
You use Cloud Identity,
you do a federation, so on.
But also, with GKE
On-Prem, now, we're
building connections,
integrations
with your existing on-prem
IDP, such as Active Directory.
But we're also now
thinking about you
serving your customers.
So the new identity
platform we're launching
is about, how do you
provide an identity service
for your applications'
customers,
kind of extending beyond
just your developers,
but to your customers as well.
And then in terms of
access management,
GCP has its own IM
policies, native policy
for the infrastructures.
And then with
Kubernetes and Istio,
they also come with the
Kubernetes-style API and RBAC
and the Kubernetes
style of policies.
Right now, I think, with
CSP config management,
we help you distribute
those consistently
across other
clusters and meshes.
We are kind of looking to
what would it take for--
this is a common problem, right?
So today, we have it
between the new Kubernetes
system and GCP IM.
But you also have that with SQL.
You also have that with Linux.
One example we've
done in the past
is we've created a bridge
between your GCP IM
system and the Linux
permission system.
So you have this
user log-in feature.
We're looking at additional
opportunities, where
you have ping points managing
across multiple of these IM
systems.
We are looking how to build
those bridges for you.
APARNA SINHA: Anthos
is really optimized
for hybrid and multi-cloud.
And so the configuration and
policy management in Anthos
is very much based on Kubernetes
RBAC and quota management,
and Istio configuration,
and managing that
from a centralized
source of truth.
I think the question,
perhaps, is,
can that centralized source
of truth be IM, GCP IM,
for example?
AUDIENCE: Can that
source of truth
be the IM system
that we already have?
Tying in the GCP IM--
great, but I really don't
want three different systems.
APARNA SINHA: So, certainly.
As Rae mentioned, we are
doing identity federation
with active directory
through Google Cloud.
So yes.
RAE WANG: And we're
looking for ways to--
through Kubernetes
Istio, we learned,
the only way to really have
consistency across multi-cloud
is to have it attached
to an open standard.
So we're looking at, what are
the abstract concepts that
are not provider-specific
that we can leverage?
For example, namespace
is a great concept.
Service identity is another.
So we're looking at how
to evolve both GCP IM,
as well as RBAC policies,
with the community
towards an
abstraction layer that
can live on top of multiple
different platforms.
AUDIENCE: How will
it be licensed?
How am I going to buy this?
RAE WANG: Great question.
You want to speak to that.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah,
so the licensing,
it's a subscription
license that is
based on a per vCPU managed
by the platform as calculated
by Kubernetes metering.
So that's the model, and
it's in blocks of 100 vCPUs.
So we expect users will want to
purchase several blocks of 100
vCPUs billed monthly,
but signing up
for a subscription
for, say, a year.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
We're almost at time.
And I wonder if each of
the panelists would say--
oh, you have a question.
OK, last question.
AUDIENCE: Since this is
an AMA, I have to ask,
one horse-sized duck or
100 duck-sized horses--
which would you rather fight?
JESS ELROY: It's definitely--
it's got to be the
duck-sized horses,
because the horse-sized duck
is just way too dangerous.
One big individual
horse-sized duck--
APARNA SINHA: And we're
microservices, you know?
JESS ELROY: Yeah,
we're microservices.
We don't like the
one monolithic thing.
[LAUGHTER]
APARNA SINHA: We'll migrate
it for you, if you need.
MODERATOR: My final
question for the panelists
is, if there is one talk
that didn't already happen,
is there something that you
would like to share and ask
people to check it out for the
rest of the Next conference?
APARNA SINHA: Yeah, so,
I think, on Thursday--
I don't remember
the exact time--
but on Thursday, sometime
in the afternoon,
there is a talk on connecting
many clusters to Anthos.
I would recommend that talk.
The presenters are Matt DeLio
and, I think, Ian [INAUDIBLE],,
but Matthew DeLio,
if you look that up.
JESS ELROY: Hey, I'm talking
tomorrow if you guys are free--
security spotlight.
CHEN GOLDBERG: I don't
remember when is the time,
but I think what
we hear many people
talk about in the context
of Anthos is governance.
So there is a session with John
on Anthos config management.
You remember when it is?
I can check that, but
definitely, just look and look
for Anthos config
management session.
I would recommend that.
ALBERTO MAESTRO: There's
a couple of sessions
around service mesh.
I'm very excited
about the things
that we are showing to help
modernize the data plane.
And so, the sessions from
Dan Siruli and David Monroe,
they're both
extremely interesting,
so I recommend those.
CHEN GOLDBERG: And,
Rae, do you have a talk?
RAE WANG: Yeah, I don't
remember the exact time.
We have a session--
security best
practice for hybrid.
That's a joint session
between an engineer recording
from Anthos config management
and [INAUDIBLE],, who's
a product manager
from networking.
So these two config
and networking
together solves your
biggest security problems.
APARNA SINHA: Yeah,
network policies
and overall [INAUDIBLE].
MODERATOR: Excellent.
So thank you all for being here.
And thank you, panelists,
for giving this talk.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]